I have done that I mean awed.
I've never known the writer before.
Ah, don't be.
annoying me either
I haven't  written a long time.
My wife she ... left me.
Anyway .. Listen, uhhm.
have be with me.
Thank you.
What do you do ?
I'm a writer.
Really ?
I don't want to drop you with this weather coming up.
I've got a guest room ..
You can use it for the night.
Let's have some breakfast.
I noticed this door has to be re-framed.
You don't have to fix anything.
Paul, I want to.  Deal ?
Who said you could read the script ?
The stories are not good enough.
I can help you.
We'll never have time to do all that.
I said it might take a little bit longer.
I heard a woman scream.
Did you hear it ?
You always tend to imagine the worst.
And what is that ?
black butterfly.
I had it done in prison.
Are you expecting somebody ?
Paul !  Not too far.
Listen we're uhmm .. looking for this woman, by any chance you've seen her ?
are looking for you .. or me.
I never going back.
I just wanted to show you some real,
sorry for the scare.
Where're you going Paul ?
We had an agreement.
Who heard a woman scream ?
I imagined that, right ?
I invite you to my home.
I'm a prisoner, in my own house !
Don't make me hurt you.
I've been calling you for days.
Run, now !
Halt ! !
All we did is play games, Paul !
Is he gonna kill us ?
Get up ! !
It's your fault the sherriff's dead.
How does it feel to see a real murder ?
I didn't kill anybody !  You did ! !
What did you do to her ?
You're finally starting to show .. some imagination.
run
Let her go, Jack !  Give up ! !
You still don't get it, do you Paul ?
I'm the one writing the story.
I have a better ending of mine.